trapé hier fort sur rtl depuis sa sortie
le gouvernement et les députés en marche
démène pour expliquer qu'il ne s'agit
pas d'un matraquage mais d'un efforts
demandés aux français dans le combat
pour l'écologie
écoutez deux d'entre eux d'abord amélie
de montchalin députés en marche de
l'essonne puis benjamin griveaux porte
parole du gouvernement
la réalité de la transition c'est
d'aider les ménages a justement faire
évoluer leur comportement quand on a
aimé nicolas hulot eh bien on assume
d'avoir une fiscalité comportement vous
ne voudrez pas sur ces sujets là nous
n'avons pas l'habitude de changer nos
fusils des pôles lorsqu'on s'engage dans
la transition énergétique
on le fait jusqu'au bout denis tillinac
ils ont raison finalement c'est aux
français à changer de comportement la
voiture c'est fini le tout pétrole
c'est à tout le monde y compris les
politiques
il yad'autres ya d'autres façons
d'inciter les français à utiliser moins
leur bagnole
inconso mémoire autrement que de ce
matraquage fiscal qui pénalise
évidemment une plus modeste
d'ailleurs est ce que finalement comme
l'augmentation du top s'est pas ouvert
l'écologie c'est bien quand ça concerne
les autres mais moins bien quand ça vous
touche directement
ça c'est un principe français nous on
est pour on est tous pour le changement
sauf si ça nous affecte personnellement
non c'est une vérité prosaïque qui se
déguise sous les grands mots de
transition énergétique ou changement
même de modèle économique s'est de tout
temps mais particulièrement aujourd'hui
les gouvernements font leurs fins de
mois avec
les taxes à la pompe donc ce n'est pas
très nouveau la seule différence c'est
qu'on essaye d'habiller sa de grandes
oreilles en effet denis la raison sera
peut-être la seule foi de l'émission
j'aurai un point d'accord avec lui enfin
c'est vrai que non mais les dd il ya des
gens qui ont pas le choix on leur dit il
faut arrêter le pétrole il faut arrêter
la bagnole si vous êtes dans la france
périphérique vous n'avez pas le choix
d'autant qu'en même temps on abandonne
les services publics est de moins en
moins de deux trains pour desservir ces
zones
donc ça ne peut être que dans le cadre
d'une politique globale si si vous si
vous le faites de manière brutale il ya
des gens qui ne pourront pas s'adapter
tout simplement à sa gouvernement dit
oui mais on est en place
une façon pour les gens de changer de
véhicule ou la prime à la conversion
c'est déjà ça mais ça doit être une
politique beaucoup plus globale de
transport il ya des coins de france où
vraiment vous ne pouvez pas même si vous
êtes écologique à 150%
vous ne pouvez pas vous passer d'une
voiture et dont vous êtes obligés de
payer ses taxes insensé avons que ça ne
date pas seulement de macron salaire de
la chine pour le gouvernement 39
milliards record battu
si on en revient au fait sauf erreur de
ma part parce que pour être maître chez
pas eu le temps d'aller vérifier donc
j'ai peut-être contredit mais je ne
pense pas il ya augmentation de la
taxation sur le diesel pas sur l'essence
l'essence et le prix de l'essence qui
monte pour d'autres raisons et parce que
le présence de baril et donc donc déjà
il faut pas amalgamer diesel essence il
n'y a pas de matraquage fiscal sur
l'essence il n'y a pas de matraquage
fiscal quand même c'est pas du tout le
fond de numéros médias dwyer 80 % de
taxe sur l'essence mais pas que lui
sinon pas rien a ni plus ni moi mais eux
manipulent ce soir l'essentiel du prix
d'essence ces détails tentation de la
taxation de l'essence reste donc la
question il faut l'associer à construire
sur le dit si on s'intéresse au fait si
on s'attache pas aux faits mais juste à
cogner sur macro c'est un autre sujet
alors sur le diesel des babioles aux
jeunes sur le diesel bien sûr que les
deux points de vue apparemment
contradictoires sont justes c'est à dire
que bien entendu que ce sont les gens
les moins privilégiés qui trinquent déjà
c'est souvent lui qui a acheté des
voitures diesel et ensuite de toute
façon on leur a dit pendant x et acheter
du district nous avons changé de voiture
c'est exact maintenant ça fait quand
même quelques années qu'on dit qu'on va
arrêter sur le disent elle qu'on va
augmenter progressivement les taxes
parce que le diesel est plus polluant
que l'essence est donc ça se défend si
dire on peut pas laisser on a eu tort de
faire cette politique d'inciter au
diesel et il faut qu'on aura par les
erreurs du passé et lexis avec le talon
d'achille du gouvernement c'est assez
embêtant parce que il baisse les charges
et c'est absolument vrai mais tout cet
âne il est dans l'esprit des gens par
ces augmentations de et baisse les
charges validé par des augmentations de
taxes parce que oui les licences et tous
les sens c'est pas de sa faute mais
n'empêche que les gens bien que
l'essentiel c'est de cesser d impôt le
gaz qui aussi bien augmenter c'est pas
de la faute parce que c' est indexé sur
le prix de l'essence du bugue elle-même
mais n'empêche que donc tout ça est en
train de de daynile et dans l'esprit et
dans le portefeuille des gens
les gains de pouvoir d'achat qui peut
avoir de de la baisse des charges donc
eh oui c'est un mauvais truc et je crois
que c'est alors pour le coup absolument
hypocrite et ségolène royal a eu raison
de le souligner de dire que c'était de
l'écologie c'est pas de l'écologie c'est
que le gouvernement ne faisant pas
d'économie parce que ni n'arrive pas et
c'est très difficile de faire des
économies mais il n'a pas fait
d'économies sur le train de vie de
l'état sur à part sur les collectivités
locales
bah qu'est ce qui fait il fait comme lui
on fait tous les gouvernements avant lui
il augmenter les taxes perçues pour
voter c'est que ça donne une impression
duplicité
et dire que la main de maître sur le
coup de l'écologie le principe d'une
taxe comportementale il faut voir ce que
c'est c'est on va monter quelque chose
pour que les gens changent de
comportement mais là on peut pas changer
de comportement c'est que non seulement
on va commencer à rendre hommage à
ségolène royal
julie anguille sous roche non mais
attendez vous pouvez pas vous avez tort
de tessa j'ai toujours beaucoup défendu
ségolène royal qui a plein de qualités
mais enfin il est sûr qu'elle
n'arriverait pas pouvoir non mais si on
a fallu un tout autre sujet si on
revient dessus j'ai arrêté de favoriser
diesel défavorisés le diesel ça incite
aussi mais un peu plus à chaque voiture
diesel comédiens ont enjambé par
ailleurs attendait comme ça c'était
kolélas écologique ça dépend c'est
écologique c'est pour la santé publique
parce que le dlc des particules mais je
rencontre me disent ne fait pas de co2
si on veut lutter contre le
réchauffement
il faut favoriser le diesel si on veut
lutter contre le cancer il faut
favoriser maintenant quand même parce
que les gens auxquels baladera
l'innovation j'essaie de finir leur écot
l'origine exacte est-ce que celui de
ségolène royal c'est bien ça dans le
dispositif fiscaux dead à la transition
énergétique pour faire des travaux chez
soi parce que c'est la même chose sur
les sanctions qui vont frapper les gens
dont on dit qu'ils ont des passoires
énergétiques les malheurs unis peuvent
rien et donc on va maintenant les
sanctionner si leurs logements ne sont
pas assez et en gt cours et toutes ces
jeunes là on est en train de retirer pas
par méchanceté pas par pas pour taper
express sur les pauvres gens c'est
simplement qu'il ya plus d'argent il ya
plus d'argent et je reviens un point de
départ parce que ce mouvement ne fait
pas les économies qu'il avait promis
qu'il ferait il se débrouille pour
harassé de 80 à 95 % de vos
téléspectateurs contre moi je dirais que
en évitant les vitesses à 80 km 1 ont
réduit la consommation
alors ça l'a libéré avant tout de ne pas
être d'accord dans les rames seront là
on peut ne pas être d'accord mais c'est
comportementale veut dire qu'on dit vous
roulerez p90 vous l'aurais 80 où on on
vous force à changer votre comportement
mais on ne peut pas forcer les gens de
plus décentes et cette voiture ni à se
réchauffer chez eux
techniques que vous abordiez alexis je
vous donne la parole denis ensuite c'est
aux testeurs de l'électrique est ce que
finalement c'est bon ou pas pour le
climat on avait un article fort
intéressant dans le figaro là dessus
donc devoir revoir un extrait sur
lefigaro.fr la voiture électrique n'émet
aucun d'aix dioxyde de carbone en
roulant mais sa fabrication
les boucles polluantes de celles de
voitures thermiques la solution après on
sera offert il faut faire les batteries
qui généralement sont faites à partir de
métaux rares qui sont alors on pollue en
afrique en chine
enfin les chinois pollue en afrique
exactement et donc du coup handicapés de
pollution chez nous mais au niveau de la
planète il ya quand même de la pollution
denis les gouvernements pas plus macron
que ses prédécesseurs manque
d'imagination il faut une transition
énergétique il faut vraiment une
révolution écologique ça veut dire qu'on
leur évolution dans le mode de
production de consommation de
d'aménagement du territoire pour que les
joueurs gens soient au plus près de leur
boulot et c'est pas avec des mesurettes
comme ça que ça changera quoi que ce
soit ça exaspère les gens ça nourrit le
populisme et ça fait monter les
niveau d'excellence vous voyez la
punition et s'associe l'écologie fini
sur les 80 alors je voudrais rassurer
olivier je roule beaucoup sur des
petites routes corréziennes et autre
personne ne le respecte cra sociale et
80 km où il perçoit aujourd'hui
désolidariser la civilité n'utilise
jamais puisque vous avez un fayot 14 des
flics et roule à 75
ça fait la queue exaspère celui qui
respecte ces failles ont provoqué
d'accident
c'est absurde olivier duhamel nous
prédisait combien 85 % d'internautes qui
serait d'accord avec l'idée que c'est du
matraquage et bah vous vous trompez
ollier ses 70 ans il jouit de sa
disgrâce c'est ça cette affaire cela
permet à collecter je prévois vre
sondages
mais ça ce n'est quelques commentaires
quand même de nos internautes alors
henry qui nous dit c'est une mesure donc
celle de deux taxes et la finlande c'est
une mesure qui n'a pour objet que de
continuer le racket permanent des
automobilistes sous couvert d'une cause
louable pour ses cris c'est juste du
matraquage veilleurs 69 aimerait que le
gouvernement commence par montrer le bon
exemple sur les déplacements des
ministres et si je nous dit ce n'est pas
si facile dans les campagnes donc tout
ça résume un petit peu plus tôt ce sera
les vélos sais pas si vous avez vu
maintenant taxer les vélos alors c'est
le coup de [ __ ] corps et ben vous
allez vous là on entre un pack de cartes
grises pour les vélos soit le texte qui
serait pas qu'il faudrait pas qu'ils
soient volés etc
mais à la fin ça sera pour faire une
taxe parce que de toute façon il ya
besoin d'eux les nouvelles mobilités ça
fait des nouvelles taxations que vous
allez voir je suis pour la marche à pied
mais trop donc je n'avance que de taxer
non mais je pense que ça ça passe par
une révolution des transports en commun
au lieu que ce soit quelque chose qu'on
laisse la baule il faut commencer par la
base les gens ne prennent pas leur
bagnole par plaisir il y en a parfois
mais enfin c'est une minorité
s'ils ont un moyen de transport
alternatif crédible
ils le prendront voilà et c'est pas en
mettant une taxe que ça va changer
comportement des gens les 6e on va
proches le site de production le bureau
de celui qui travaille c'est encore
mieux
mais là ça demande plus élevée et faudra
le faire sinon ça ira pas bien loin